[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about sacred
geometry and the chest ahed Rijn we have
Frank Chester joining us on the show
hello thank you for coming on we really
appreciate it
thank you very much we're super excited
we're very grateful to Brock Pierce for
making the introduction happen it was
such a blessing going up to your home in
Marin and being able to dive deeper into
all of your art and your sculpting and
your sacred geometrical work for those
that don't know Frank Chester is an
artist a sculptor and a geometrician
focused on the sacred chest ahed Hren he
has taught art for more than 30 years in
high schools and colleges exploring the
relation between form and spirit and you
can find his link in the bio Frank
Chester dot-com all right Frank let's
start things off with one of our
favorite questions we like asking our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world a direction of
our world well I think first off that
the direction of our world is exactly
where it's supposed to be and I like it
and I'm pleased to be here and capacity
that I and everybody else's can develop
here is a real gift so living here on
the planet between birth and death is
it's the best um I would be happy to
come back again I love that you're very
optimistic and yeah it's very very
powerful um I want to I want to ask you
about your journey now let's just jump
right into it the amount of gratitude
you had there was great you're born and
raised in Hollywood California and I
want to know how you picked up your
interest in art and sculpting and
geometry
well my dad taught me all these skills
how to make things he could make
anything and now I can too
and so being exposed to him had a lot to
do with what the whole thing but I never
thought I would be an artist but never I
never had an art classic in high school
on but I got to into college and I was a
first major and I didn't like it and so
I used to draw cartoons and my roommate
took cartoons who art teachers said hey
look at this guy can do so our teacher
said hey send him over so I went over
and I really liked him and so I started
and changed my major to art and I
graduated I went to Cranbrook Academy of
art for my MFA which was a one of top
three schools in the nation at the time
so that's kind of what happened and when
you were with your father and you saw
your father being able to build whatever
that he wanted to create it and then
that inspired you as well to be able to
start tinkering and playing what were
you most interested in tinkering with
when you were young
with him yeah with my dad yeah yeah Oh
my dad he was such a craftsman I mean
when he made something man that thing
was beautiful and so I always competed
with him whenever I could I tried to
compete with him to do as good as he
could and only now can i but it took me
so long to get as good as he was and so
of course we made model airplanes model
airplane model airplanes and I was in
and as and he's dig state national
contest with gliders and and I won a
Awards with that and then when I got to
be about 16 then my dad says okay how
about a hot rod I said okay
and so he and I built a hot rod
I drove that way past after I graduated
from college so you know between the
airplanes and the cars it was great
cha it's great teenager life I had a
great teenager life those are both very
strong ways of understanding our world
is being able to craft things by hand as
well as go for both model airplane side
things as well as the cars
those are good ways of understanding how
things work Wow sure was good for me yes
it was and then also you buy just 30
years of teaching in high school and
colleges how did you then deposit was it
partly about your father teaching you
that you got inspired to teach others as
well well no I mean during those those
teaching years I was teaching art and
industrial arts so I could use the
machines and apply them artistically
where the artist couldn't use the
machines they didn't know about him and
then just those people didn't know how
to design so I came running in the
middle between those two extremes and I
think that's really what really helped
me and so when I got started to cheat I
didn't really plan to be a teacher and I
didn't like it at first but I got to a
point where I just loved it and what I
did is I decided that one day that I had
all these ideas and I thought why don't
I just give them my to my students so I
gave all my creative energy and all my
ideas away and more you couldn't believe
the results I got and you couldn't
believe how much it helped me not only
the students so this is interesting how
you both had a solid footing in the idea
of building in manufacturing a car a
plane but also on the design and art
side of things when when at times some
people can go deep into one of those two
you were able to find a strong yes I
found that middle ground and I needed
both
yes I needed both and that's how you can
build things and yes into the reality as
well um that's right and then you you
also you mentioned then this you know
this process of figuring out that you
want to teach that you want to open
source even your ideas I did yes
tell us about this yeah it was really
great because if I had done it just by
myself in my studio and you know made
the art and whatever the ideas wouldn't
come as quick and I wouldn't have seen
things being developed okay so that I
could I could do something else I could
have a question about something and then
when I would see it being made I would
have better questions about it and so my
questions got better so it's great
journey really great yeah it's you
opened up the information flows and let
other people build on top of them build
yeah and I got to see them develop yeah
and what were some of your favorite
aspects about the 30 years that you
spent teaching like the young people
what did you find most interesting about
those teaching processes with them
that I could put life and back into
teaching into school and I could I could
invigorate I could motivate and I could
take the dullness out of all the
experiences I had in school because I
went through those I never allowed the
students to become dull and I they were
very enthusiastic used to hang around on
my door I used to run to my class so
that that's really nice that was great
yeah that's the yeah his pinnacle
teaching is when the kids are running to
the class because they're so interesting
yeah yeah I ran away from the class
alright let's talk about how you picked
up secret geometry actually when we were
at your house and you said that oh I
only picked up the sacred geometry work
20 years ago and that was when you were
60 yes that's right yeah what happened
is I retired and I really didn't know
what to do but it did know I wanted to
go back to school so I had already taken
so many art classes well why don't I do
something else so I decided to take a
science class and in this science class
the lady who was teaching form Studies
introduced the whole class to platonic
forms which I hadn't heard of I mean of
course I've heard of the cube you know
everybody knows what a cube is but I had
no idea there was any kind of deep
thought behind it I had no idea so when
I started to look at these five forms
especially the cube and I was very
interested in the queue because cube is
is basically everything that's different
and and that's based on the earth so the
Earth experience we have here okay is
based on the cube and the quality of
being different so I started to study
these platonic forms and the first one
that came in to the world is a tetanus
four triangles and then the second one
that comes in is the octahedron unless
all triangles - and seem thank the last
one that comes in is the cube so I
started a singer out well and the cube
has no triangle plus that and the cube
has no triangles that has what kind of
no triangles what it means no no
triangles on a cube all squares right
yeah everything's 90 degrees
yes no triangles and so my first idea
was is to put the first form which is a
tetrahedron and put it into a cube and I
did and I thought my god that's really
neat so then I went from the cube to the
octahedron and I noticed that they would
go into each other and also they were
opposites and that really perked up my
interest in it so I have a cube there's
the cube and here's an octahedron
so these are polarity difference these
are opposites okay and the reason is is
because this comes from here
okay and it will go into the cube like
this and put the top back on
yeah yes yes okay okay okay so the form
inside is the opposite of the one
outside and the reason is is because the
cube is all planes yes and this is all
points yes so points and planes are
opposite points and planes are opposites
and this one they are and so there's a
point here and there's a plane on the
inside on the face of the tetrahedron
yeah I mean or the octahedron yeah well
what happens is that when you take the
cube and you cut this corner off in that
corner yeah that makes that shape
exactly yes yes when you cut it at this
plane level it makes that shape that's
right yes these are called truncations
truncations okay so you cut the corners
off yes and you get that inside now if
you take the one inside and you cut the
top off which you're the points are
called vertices but I'll call them
points yes yes if I cut the points off
it makes a cube yes yes and then if if I
cut them if I cut these points off okay
then it becomes a cube and then a new
one of these can go in that cube by
cutting off the cube again so it can go
all down to infinity and all the way
huge so this is a polarity this is this
is a an opposite mm-hmm this is an
opposite of this okay oh so this is
what's really neat about this this has
this has six points
six vertices and this has six planes
mm-hmm yes okay yes so but this has
eight points one two three four five six
seven eight and that has eight please
this has eight planes see how wonderful
that is yeah it's just unbelievable so
this is based on eight and this is based
on six because it has six points this
has eight points mm-hmm so six and eight
so when I saw this going on
I said well where's the seven ah because
it's gotta be you know I'm between
between 8 and 6 or 6 and hey there's got
to be 7 so I went to instructor I said
you know where's the 7 and she says
there isn't one I said what do you mean
there isn't the 6 and an 8
come on give me a break you know so I
said well I said in between these two
there has to be a 7 she's as well in
between these two is this 4
well this is halfway between the cut in
the corners off and this it makes a
12-sided form uh-huh
so that's not helping me all at all
because I want the seventh mm-hmm okay
so after that class I was inspired to
work on seven so that's all I did as to
work on seven so since there wasn't one
I thought well I know there's eight
points there or eight points here and
six points here why don't I make seven
points
nothing except on it so what I did was I
took
I took a seed that I found outside my
apartment and that seed maybe I have it
over here no I don't see it but is it in
one I'll look again here let me look and
see if I could find that seed here right
there I got it okay
love how interactive this is
this is an amber amber sieved amber tree
had all these little holes and I thought
us is perfect so I took seven sticks the
same length that I put them in these
holes like this and I tried to keep them
equal this is a part you know so that
one would be you know that would be try
keep this equal and that's not quite eat
both oh I kept going around and keep
adjusting them until I put seven
together that were equidistant okay yeah
yes thank you
some of these little poke holes don't
hold it you good all right there's seven
sticks okay they're all the same length
and I I got them all the same distance
apart
I can see that I need to put hobby one
here see I'm already doing it I'm
already starting to do this again
and so I connected all these points like
these are connected you know these are
all connected right and the shape I got
have ten sides as seven sticks makes ten
sides I thought what's going on here
something's yeah this is going to be the
more difficult than I thought all right
so I put this aside and I went back to
studying the difference between these
two no here's a cube and here's an
octahedron okay these are these are
minerals this is this is this is fool's
gold fool's gold
this is fool's gold and it forms into a
perfect cube pyrite and this is this is
feldspar and it works into a perfect
octahedron there it is there should be a
seven though you know in minerals but I
found out there isn't because seven
doesn't spiral it doesn't grow crystals
grow like this but the seven turns
though that was really cool then what I
found out now you can see here's up dos
bar here and you can see that it has
these purple parts right here it's
already trying to be a comic cube see
how you cut that things off that's the
natural okay the seven is not natural
all right
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take a
pen here and show you about seven mm-hm
and I discovered the I discovered the
chest ahed Rijn how to have a difference
between here that made sense and nothing
in geometry made sense in Frank we can
we can angle towards this way okay we're
gonna okay so first off I'll put I'll
draw a cube and octahedron a little
harder to draw because they have so many
sides it's basically like this and so
yeah yeah yeah alright so here's the
question mark what is this mm-hmm yes
it's a six in the answer question matter
so that is basically what I want to show
you but I think I better show you how I
found this though I started by showing
you I put seven sticks in mud or nests
into that piece of clay or into that
seat well as you could see I didn't work
so I'm going to show you how I did it
this will show you how I found this form
so you can't take traditional geometry
and quarters off and truncate him
doesn't work so something had to be
different that hasn't been done in the
world before okay so the next thing I
did was I took seven fishing floats
they're kind of half white and half red
I know you've seen them and I put seven
of them together like this with my hands
with a piece of clay in the middle this
is what I got which is pretty cool but
that's just not separate I mean it's got
seven holes but the problem is it's got
this big gap here seen that big gap yeah
that ball and that ball and that ball
and that ball I push them together they
can't they don't touch yes so there's a
big gap here too
well that's not gonna work so what I
decided to do is instead of working from
the center to the periphery I started to
go from the periphery to the center and
so I took a ball of clay I know where
the seven points were because I already
done so what I did is I started my
sculptor so what I did is I started to
carve these holes these volcanoes and -
a sphere seven volcanoes and this is
what I came up with but the only way I
could have done that is because of this
get here an artist don't care about gaps
we just keep carving and this one turned
turned in differently because when this
came together this is what the shape
looked like this is the actual one I did
20 years ago so when I carved in here
one of them became a triangular and one
of them became forth one two three four
one two three four I said Wow why don't
they all the same than I ever thought
that our triangle and a four or seven
yeah yeah yeah so then I made this in
two planes only
here the planes okay so the first plane
that I dug out huh there's a triangle
right and then when I carved out the
other one they became this shape and
here's there is the triangle or that
there's the quadrilateral and there's a
triangle that's a seven sided form right
there seven sided form has four and
three and this has four triangles and
three quadrilaterals seven and this
surface and this surface are perfectly
even and square-footage perfect and it
has seven points so my original one with
the seven points worked out pretty good
but there were when I made the the the
seed with all the toothpicks in it there
was a problem because I had to take away
three of him and make him shorter but
which ones so through the process I
found
that
you saw one process that I took that I
took the tetrahedron curse the
tetrahedron and I have a stick here
somewhere maybe yeah I put that stick in
here all the way down to the bottom and
then put it back in to cube that stick
lines up with my corners yeah and this
is the corner here but the pop okay you
know this edge here this edge here this
is root 2 this is root 2 that's root 2
this is root 2 all over 2 root 2 that's
amazing
all right so what I did was is I got a
video that shows this what I did it was
I opened up the top of a tetrahedron
which has never been done before
nobody's ever done this I opened up the
top of the tetrahedron and this blue
shape start to appear mmm-hmm so there
it is the tetrahedron inside a big
tetrahedron now when I opened it up you
can see that blue shape there there it
is again
so that surface that you see is green
there but now it's come in the green
lines is exactly I stopped at exactly
one of most equal to a triangle so and
watch it being read you see it reduce to
reduce to 1 now it's both all number one
yes that's one that's what I knew
exactly where to stop
so
this is where to stop the blue my stop
for the blue well it just ate that
tetrahedron opened up like this and when
it got to be an equal surface with this
I stopped if I continue to open this up
this blue would become twice the sizes
the red it would be two triangles one on
top of the other what's interesting
about this is that this fits into a cure
just like the tetrahedron except it's
been twisted so set up being like this
now this is good enough said of being
all the way to the corners yes I twisted
it and when I twisted it it opened it up
and now the blue touches here all seven
points touched the form that's your cue
and that was the beginning of a
tetrahedron how I found a seven sided
form that had all the qualities that I
was looking for for a seven so then I'll
go back I'll show you this
so just the Haven looks like this
nothing like that mm-hmm okay so this
had points right this had eight points
mm-hmm this has seven this has six okay
so this form has eight triangles so
they'd like to have eight triangles I
used for yes one two three four
yes one two three four on this side I
use these kites yeah yeah you call them
kites yeah they're like okay yep and
there's three kites and there's three of
them one two three okay so there's one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12
that makes four times three is 12 right
well this is one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve this
also equals twelve
this has 12 edges mm-hm
it has 12 edges this has edges also 12
this has 12 edges this central this has
12 edges yeah I mean give me a break you
know what I mean I start with sticks and
mud no see I mean it's just it's just
insane what my life has been like going
through this it's just it's just been
fantastic
so the to see this this innumerable
abstraction happened from a forum I
found subjectively yeah okay yes is the
direction I've been going for the last
20 years is to study where this is okay
so one of the things about it is this so
four so four platonic shaped solids
there was no seven all right
they I was introduced to it true they
were solids and when I saw him there
wasn't anything solid about him I saw
them as edges only I saw that the inside
was empty okay and so that's the way I
approach it how I was able to start this
this whole idea is going in to the
center and going out to the periphery
yes and going from the periphery back
into the center and then I found the
center so I can show you another thing
that's really neat
this is the octahedron this is the cube
now the octahedron and the cube are made
up with three planes and they're both
are all the same size
so these are opposites so in between
here and there has to be the 7/2 that's
being done so it's three here and three
here they're all the same size except
they're different configuration this has
taken the square and gone across it
diagonally which is root 2 this one has
taken the square and crossed it so this
is actually a plus and this is a
multiplier all right so if I take these
and I put them together and the chest
ahim it looks like this okay so this has
three one two three there are four four
sides four quadrilaterals and it has the
other ones which are dealing with the
cube they also have four sides so all
together this is 24 this is 12 and this
is 12 and it's right in between and the
thing is beautiful I think it's just
gorgeous
this is an interval my work is all about
intervals and interval I never realized
that that's what that is I this this
form represents how to balance
polarities okay so this is an music this
is an interval and you can't hear you
can't have music without intervals and
intervals you can't see them and you
can't hear them
you could only feel them Wow
so an interval is my work and this is an
interval for okay so I'll get more more
into this balancing of a polarity yes
you got two notes what's in between an
interval if you think on pianos has
black keys those are intervals your half
notes you
there's an infinite amount of those
laughs there's an infinite amount of
those half yes yes well there's also
quarters
yes quarters and yeah hey Frankie well
yeah
twelve so and you found the interval
between the 6 and the center of the 8
that's in a [ __ ] yeah and then that's
nobody's ever found that so
so I thought I'd do a little sacred
geometry I was gonna do it at the very
start but I think I got involved with
this being in front of me that I just
kind of didn't start like I wanted okay
so I'm gonna talk about this form you
see in front of you here is sacred
geometry and why a sacred geometry is
because it had nothing to do with
mathematics
there's no abstraction it came from
sacred geometry sacred John Barry
consists of three things a pencil
a straightedge
and a compass
this is the first compass in the world
it's a tweak of the branch Wow
this is how it started to make a perfect
circle this makes a perfect circle every
single time
now the Egyptians four thousand years
ago they would take two people and then
they've tie a rope between them around
their waist and one would go around the
other that's how you three yes Wow
and then when he got lower he started
there's this guy's turn and he went
around the other way
Wow yeah and may came two circles so
this little guy here all I have to do is
take your son or daughter down on the
beach and find an old dead stick around
with a branch off it break it off and
put it in the sand and you can draw the
most fantastic sacred geometry in the
world without using a ruler you just
need another stick so I decided you know
to really show this I thought I would
put a kind of an end on here so it's now
I've got something I can mark well if I
I'm gonna show you everything I'm gonna
show you a whole thing all you need is a
stick mm-hmm with a branch one little
branch off it so if I draw a circle here
I'm be easy but it's hard to keep that
point you know what I did I put a an
eraser on the end of my compass oh yeah
didn't yeah you didn't move around so
yeah we're gonna how kind of a mess here
for a while maybe now it still moves
around but if I draw one circle here
say I want to use this stick to show you
that this is all you need
yeah okay so if I draw if I go across
here means I took a bunch of points yes
center point and connect them that makes
the line that's the first thing comes
into the world as a line the point is in
a dimension that's the first dimension
okay anyway so then if I go out here and
I do it again if I draw another circle
okay I forgot this guy up
okay this is known as one okay one
that's the first amount one but here
there's something else going on because
right in between these two we have
another line and we want to know what
that was that line is
so you know I get freehand but I if I
use this stick this is how I would do it
right I give the stick now this is
accurate if I had done it a little
better with a real compass the real
compass okay this is consciousness this
is the sign of consciousness and this is
polarities and in between here is the
interval okay so okay okay so the the
polarities are the two separate ends of
a compass and the interval is 'm between
them that's right so this should be 1
and it is my stick drill what
mm-hmm so that means that there's
something else going on in here okay
that is going to happen because this is
accurate all right so
if I make a stick as long as this one
here
this is supposed to be more accurate but
if I bring this to a point not a point I
mean it is I'm kind of disappointed
that's not as accurate as I want it but
I had tetrahedron what the cube yep yep
yeah there was this one but I had one in
a cube
well anyway believe me that this red
line okay etc he drew the cube right
down there and I had one what the stick
it over oh yeah that's right here I got
it it's right here not here we go wow
that's not that yeah that's okay
but I happen when I could remove the
stick no not over there this one but I
had one that you could take the stick
out of it here it is
okay let's see if this is any closer I
hope it is cuz I'd like to get this even
though I use that that's a little
shorter okay so if I'm telling you this
is perfect except my stick isn't I think
the reason is is because I added the
eraser and the circle got a little
smaller or bigger
if I don't add the racer let's see what
it but I was like oh yeah with the
eraser got a little bit might have been
a little bit smaller ha ha see there we
go if I make the circle correct yeah
without that eraser on it yeah yeah yeah
then the red becomes smaller but that's
because of this instrument yeah yeah
maybe I should do it again let's see
they're not gonna he could go off the
paper I think he'll be alright
well no I won't work
and go trip let's do another one another
at the point there put about here maybe
there yeah okay
I remember this is what the stick I'm
twig I got off the beach yeah okay all
right now let's see let's see if this
gets any better there it is
now there it is okay I can see we just
had a tweak problem we have the eraser
at the end yeah eraser problem is that
is that can you see that that's accurate
and what does that tell us
okay what does that tell us that tells
us that that dis is exactly between you
two points anak you remember we had this
this part mm-hmm this part see how it's
accurate yeah yeah yeah and that line
brings in the third dimension that's how
you get that third dimension and that's
where all these photonic farms come from
you can see it that I had that little
stick in there that's how you get the
third dimension yeah so the so the first
is this line the first is a line that's
the first dimension the first is the
line yep and then the second the second
so you wanna know where the second is
all right let me show you this is the
second earth dimension cherry it's a
plane like the watch watch this yes
that's the same size yes same size is my
circle right
okay does that right yeah the plane the
plane is and then here's the line on
that circle that we were just yeah this
is a red line and the red line is the
third dimension is it third dimension
because it can fit in the is this an
email cube okay the diagonal in acute
it's a dying on the cube and it's Nona
abstractly this root 3 root 3 this is 1
so that's root 3 so where's root 2 is
the plane no at that no no root 1 is
this yes
well that's 101 1 where's root 2 yes
where is root 2 this is this red line no
no no that's root 3 that's root 3 see
look how I have that root freeze look at
ya isn't that great it's great yeah yeah
I did that with a stick yeah thank you
so what I'm trying to tell you here is
that this is sacred
where's the root - okay well let me just
show you one more thing and I'll tell
you where it is okay okay so look at
this
there's root sorry again see that how it
is so if I go like this watch this now
there's your three yeah right
that's magic that's absolutely sacred
unbelievable who did this this has been
known for thousands of years
okay root to all right
I drew it this one here oh I'm not gonna
try to make this accurate okay but it is
accurate this distance right here is one
all right if you take this this is up
here and this this is up here and you
draw it across that makes a perfect
square
yes that's root 2 L root 2 is a 2 root 2
is the diagonal on a plain square where
yeah that's amazing okay this is that
amazing there's no stick you know I got
the beach that's amazing so that's why
he's been able to be done for thousands
of years thousands and thousands of
years don't give me a break it don't
need all this abstraction oh it is it
all stick off the beach and your son or
daughter can make these circles and make
these circles and make a circle now and
what's the significance of root of 1
root 2 and root 3 in terms of how it
applies to our everyday life it is what
every day like this made of that's a
good question that you have to kind of
find your own answer to okay so I'm I'm
gonna do something else that I thought
this is to me this is amazing now I
don't have to do so eraser again okay is
that maybe that's a little bit better
so if I draw a circle I make a point
here's the point and I draw a circle
and a lot of you know this already
yeah that's good yeah
yeah yeah not bad huh yeah pretty good
okay so if I go like this for a twig off
the beach what's that for a twig off the
beach and with a no eraser on the thing
yeah and it's a magic marker thing but
if I go around this remember this is the
same distance here yeah okay okay oh I
see we're okay
mm-hmm and things still trying to come
off won't be as accurate as I would like
but I want I use the stick because it's
important to realize that sacred
geometry is all about this stick awesome
anyway it's supposed to be on the same
cliff city yeah yeah okay now okay so we
made six markings around the six
markings they're perfect if I made them
all perfect see how that didn't quite
make it it's very close that's because
of the way the compass was there is okay
now in sacred geometry is has a moral
force and what I mean by that is that
the compass is a moral compass and why
that is is because you can't cheat you
can't lie it's the truth mmm absolute
truth so if I make another circle around
here like this you know it should
and it should be something like this
right oh look look oh it's there yeah
yeah yeah as thing us
I go around her like that okay that's
about right
you know everybody sees that huh we did
that already
alright I'm gonna do it again your
intersecting another circle with yeah
this is exactly huh yes okay so I'm
gonna do it again
so there's no cheating or lying it's
only true okay
no no cheating everything wherever a
line crosses is where you put the
compass yeah yeah you can't cheat this
this kind of work changes your dream
life if you do it so there's our dream
life
yeah it'll change your dream life well
how does it change our dream life it
makes if you have unlawful type of
Dreams Oh white mares whatever yeah
let's take care of that Ron you should
do some of them this practice just this
now this is what a kid can do okay so if
I go around all these points yeah and
I'm not going to be real accurate
because I'm using this stick but you
know in the sand oh it's right on I mean
you don't have this eraser thing it's
right on in the sand in a play box or in
the mud whatever and that's the
so here we go and that's what you're
showing right now is let's make sure the
ND eyes on it is okay excellent
and what well yep there it is what we
google-searched yeah see this this
little star here that's the one right in
the middle there that's this one and so
stick okay I made it with the stem there
with a stick so you can see this alright
see see the circle it's important that
you see him I haven't put all the
circles in I mean after all be here all
day with a stick but there are six
circles right with one in the center at
seven ah six circles with one in the
center six markings on the edges one
yeah many there's seven okay so and
that's this is the main this is the
Flower of Life what you've made and then
the more that you make markings you can
keep going from here make another circle
right
you could only put this compass point
okay that point where two lines cross
we're two lines cross here you can only
keep going from here from here that's
right and then what is this repeating
pattern of the flower of life if you
keep repeating this out okay
yes this makes seventh circles if I do
what Alan said to do I will get 12 of
the circles okay well and 12 and 7 or 19
19 19 is a big deal with 19 is a big
deal but 19 is the flower of life this
is the seed of life we went from 1 to 7
to 19 if we go through another layer
okay what and obviously 7 is the amount
of sides on a chest ahed Rijn yes and
then what's 19 why is that such an
important well I'm honest I'm gonna
stick with this has it simpler okay yeah
this is that you said this is the seed
of life this is a see that 19 is the
flower of life yes okay okay so wherever
these I think it's best if I mark didn't
really see what the yo what I'm talking
about here with a sacred geometry do
that okay okay wait wait let's see keep
it a little longer for for the viewers
yes okay
find my stick here's my stick okay so
this is what's really neat is if I
if I connect these points if it was
really accurate you can see that one's
accurate you just see what I'm oh this
is cool okay okay
I know what you think
[Laughter]
you
without a razor there's a six-pointed
star
yes so this six this six pointed star is
by continuing to take the where where
the the edge that these edges DS versus
ever two lines cross wherever two lines
cross and then you you're making a line
from where two lines crossed to the
exact yeah opposite to the okay oh
that's right no no only not only that
but I can do this you know I hope you
don't mind if I do it freehand I want to
do it freehand and make it quick
yes okay I'll do the best I can
okay and then you're connecting those
yes okay
okay so from here to here is from here
to here yeah so you're what you're
showing us right now is the exact
cross-section right there yeah exactly
yeah
now that's amazing yeah that the Chester
Hayden would have this in the center
yeah that means you're onto it
oh my gosh what is this all about so
what I did was this I I took the my
bigger compass here interesting
so the cross-section of the tetrahedron
is the the seed of life that's right
that's best as that yeah this is get
better it's a vibrant circle around this
okay you know if it was accurate you
know oh here's your bigger bigger
compass yeah so all right so anyway
these compasses are so cool these oh
this is a this is a really cool compass
instead of most compasses have a mostly
compass and have a oh you know what it
is it's the wrong top oh okay yeah yeah
most companies have up I love it all
right they have a bar here with a screw
and you can go like this oh yeah oh just
and it goes like that right yes this
doesn't do that this does this and then
when you want to get it really accurate
you use this and this moves the pan Wow
it's much more accurate than anything on
the planet yeah yeah anyway so I have it
cuz I have to be very accurate and my
work okay so you drew us another circle
around where these are yeah you keep
explaining why why'd you do that one now
what do you / this last circle that you
yeah it's a main thing to realize that
that is a circle yes and that that helps
you get it accurate okay
and when they show the seed of life okay
they don't have this out here but they
have a circle around this knot I mean
yeah it's like this one here see what's
this is the fruit this is a fruit of
life that's behind her there's a big one
and it has a circle around it fruit or
flower a fruit
watch this is the fruit or seed of life
okay and this is a flower of life okay
okay now to make this all you have to do
is connect all these points which we
talked about okay so this is the most
recognized as the most sacred of all
sacred geometry this one why this has
this has been found in places that are
ten thousand years old they're in the
they're in the temples in Egypt they're
in the pyramids you'll see these they're
all throughout the Renaissance and the
churches everything well this is sacred
okay goes in a cube at root 3 yeah at
root 3 yeah yeah and and so does the
justice hey drew what do you think they
were what do you think they were onto
yes yes the Chester Haven also fits in
at root 3 Frank what do you what do you
think they were onto 10,000 years ago
the the with um the ancient
civilizations why did they have the
Flower of Life inside of their art and
as part of their lives because it was
really fun to draw it was great that it
could put all these circles together and
it was not only that what it was
beautiful that it affected you it
affects you yes it affects your like I
said it affects as your dream life it
affects the moral forces in you the
moral Mahadi that fouquet yeah you'll be
more tomorrow buddy or by kids I want
you to be moral when you go to school
how are you gonna teach your kid to do
that but this is something tangible okay
that can actually practice and give them
something that's the hands-on it goes in
here and it comes from the fearing life
and I will show you more and more how
this is in the feeling life the feeling
yes correct yes okay all right so
this is also something I like to show
and what I can do is I can mm-hmm I can
use this and you take some q-tips
and you dip them in rubber cement and
when you do that to stick together how
many you know I mean you can let go and
there they are so like that and what I'm
going to do is I'll put six of them
together because that makes a hexagram
doesn't it hey I'm still thinking about
how you said that doing flowers of life
can help with children and morality
that's very interesting the compass is
really morality the compass is the moral
compass we keep talking about a moral
compass on them you're now a new compass
man what the hell they don't even know
if they're talking about they think it's
a compass and it's on a boat it's not oh
of course you could also use it that way
because it's also you know know if I
take the hexagram
mm-hmm
yeah I'm gonna put another one here why
is the Pentagon the Pentagon say it was
that again
Oh question from the audience are from
you Ron yes Jo pudding from Cleveland
Ohio asks why is the Pentagon why is
that you I think the United States
Pentagon yes that's up yes
what why is why do you think the United
States chose to make the Pentagon a
Pentagon no I don't know if I have an
answer
it's good it's good to hear I mean I
know about the pentagram and I can tell
you about it and I'll show you right
here how it's related to this Chester
Hebrew so it could be part of sacred
geometry zwei it says oh absolutely yeah
see what were you going to show with
that well no I just have to set this
down because I need to get this this
stick here out of here so I can break it
I need to have something I can brick
okay okay so here's here's the pentagram
I haven't got it done yet but almost
that's a good question I want to answer
it
okay so I could hold this up oh yeah
yeah so that's what we've been drawing
here this except I put the lines in here
but the reason I put the lines in here
to show you that a root 3 is that this
is between two equilateral triangles
perfect now let's see is that right am I
correct that is the distance between two
equilateral triangles am i right mm-hmm
same distance all the way around same
distance as root 3 so if I go back to
the circles here if I draw a line from
here to here there's root 3 and I
connect this line this line this line is
line they're equal triangles or just
like these
tell me draw that huh is that are we
okay well we we all so let's we all
Semyon root 3 is to e : all triangles I
just want root 3 is 2 equal areas okay
to equilateral triangles okay okay all
right so if I put the root 3 in the
middle of this pentagram like that in
the middle it makes a perfect cube yes
all those 12 edges are the same length
that's fantastic
look that's what's inside here there's a
cube in the middle of the chest ahed
room you can't see it it doesn't mean
it's not there that's the sacred part of
sacred geometry is that part that you
can't see they're there but you can draw
and find out that they are there prove
it this is amazing ok
how I did that I wanted to do that now
so I put this form into a circle like
this way see this circle right here
that's this circle he this big triangle
here that's this one I mean it's hard
for you to see but how I can tell you
that it's true you can see the lines
I've stretched in you see those lines
that are yeah
yes that's done yes I hope you can see
it I don't know if we just did we just
did we show okay okay now also can you
see these lines I drew in there
very nice okay
all right I love it Trey I think you can
Sam you know all right yeah okay Noah I
put these yellow highlight marks and
that's where I put the chest ahed Hren
there there there there there right
there is where the Chester Hayden is
going through this plate yes okay
so the yellow marks is where the chest
ahed Rijn is entering through the plate
so the yellow marks right here is where
the chest ahed Rijn is going through the
plate that's where it makes a sick yes
this is based on six okay and that's
where it's going through yeah so let's
check the Haven is going through here
all six points yeah see the cameras
there so now I can show the like this
can you see the six pointed star good no
good
Ron's doing it yep okay I got it so
this is a seat of life and the Chester
Hayden is going through exactly where
the six pointed star is that you saw who
you saw here okay okay
now when I look at this just a hydrant
in there it's not in the middle the
distance from here to the base isn't as
high as from the sphere of the disc to
the pop top this difference is bigger
see that same thing here from here to
the top yeah there it's good one it's
greater other words from the Green Line
down is a lot shorter than from the
Green Line up yes no question yes so I
had to deal with this for a long time
like why is this I don't like it I want
it in the middle I can't cheat whatever
so I had to live with it and I live with
it for quite a while like a year or so I
also see the cube I put in there that's
what's in there see the cube so you know
there is a cube based on what I did here
with the with the tooth with the q-tips
and you know that those are the holes of
the smaller six pointed star inside
which is just a sacred geometry okay so
I live with this for a while until one
day I decided well I think what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna put this in a
sphere yeah then I wanted to get that
sphere the same size as the disc and
touch the top mm-hmm
can you see the top right there it's
touching yeah yeah okay
so if I take the other half of this
sphere and put it on since it's not as
tall all three points touch mm-hmm all
these three points down here touch the
sphere as well as the top and that's why
it's not exactly in the middle because
it's just a hydrant is supposed to be in
the middle of a sphere
mm-hmm and the sixth point star is
supposed to be in the middle of the
equator and it's also being supposed to
be in the middle of the chest a Hebrew
now that is magic yeah that is that's
unheard of
whatever thought so then so then in in
another so what why this is magic then
is because this is like earth and that
day of getting ahead of me yes that's
exactly right now that won't come apart
yeah and so that so that this this the
the six pointed star is at the equator
that's right six point stars at the
equator that's right and then the chest
ahed Rijn is has the perfect touch
points with the edge of the sea four
points that touch the sphere also and
keeps it in the center so that the
center of the chest even in the sphere
has a six pointed star right in the
middle and right at the equator as a
cube right at the equator is a cube see
the cube in there right at the center
even the equator is a cube yes
now if I take the sphere and I put it
into a cube okay if I take a sphere and
put it into a cube the outside of the
sphere touches the very center of the
right where they of the plane yeah so I
remember how these were hitting okay so
that's the best way to explain that
all right you can see that the cube is
is right in the center and that there's
a there's a six pointed star inside the
cube there is a six pointed star inside
the cube there's also six sided cube
into the chapter Hebrew if I put a
sphere inside that little box that
little cube in there a little cube I put
a sphere in there so that the edges of
the sphere touched the faces of the cube
and I measure that in relationship to
the outside that sphere in the middle
side is the size of the core of the
earth you'd go measure it you go to any
encyclopedia or any website whatever
you'll see the size the the the cube in
the very center is proportionate to the
size of our the core as a planet yes
that's a scientist have found and some
scientists has some in the Netherlands
that says that the sphere in the center
isn't really accurate it's actually a
cube in the center it's a Cuban missle
yes this is this is scientific evidence
that has nothing to do with my work but
my work shows why okay so
I'm up put this over here yeah okay yeah
I can take you do okay now pick up the
chest to Hayden here's the check the
heater here and at the top of the
Chester Hayden there's a triangle on the
bottom there's a triangle so I haven't a
black rubber band and see that black
rubber band okay if I bring that black
rubber band down and the one on the
bottom up mmm yes it will turn into
right at the right point which is right
here with the chest hydron it makes a
perfect six point six pointed star yes
and this is showing you how that works
now the mole the most important thing to
realize is this is that when the or the
triangle that comes down and the
triangle that comes up twist in opposite
directions they go like this yes yes
I'm so excited for this part
Frank you still move so well I love it I
love it
here's the chest hidden in the earth
yeah and these points right here all
touch land masses and this of course
touches the South Pole so I did a whole
bunch of studies on maps to find out
where all these different lines were I
was very interesting interesting it's
right wolf well at least from what it
looks like one touches one touches
around Rome one touches around Denver
one touches around Tokyo yeah one
touches Kansas this is where Dorothy
came from that's where all the
Hurricanes go right oh oh that's right
oh because that one's kind of moving a
little bit in the center of the US so
that thing it shouldn't be a movie but
if it's around yeah that's Kansas that's
kind of interesting where Dorothy which
Kansas is a very massive yeah and all
you have to do is to follow that line
right up and it goes right where turn
then it goes and then what happens it
hits Kansas and then it turns that
direction and going on Internet look you
can follow the tornado go follow the
edges follow the edges follow the yellow
brick road interesting so you can follow
the edges of the book but then what
about the other edges where it comes up
through well what about the other edges
well they're very interesting
I did a studies of the coast of Asia
yeah like ones on the east coast of Asia
yeah because see some of these are
sucking and some of them are under
pressure some so depending on which line
you follow one is pressure or one a
suctioned opposite polarity sure sure
okay
just like within the heart the pressure
and the suckers yes interesting so then
it could be part of the Ring of Fire
here what the vault is the Ring of Fire
all you have to do is lay it out on a
map the Ring of Fire goes across here on
that line what about the one that is
coming through kind of like a I don't
know some of that some of its
interesting I can't explain
yeah okay in the nighttime once an time
after all I mean you know what I'm
stating is pretty you know be weird be
happy it says over there what's being
weird and being happy yeah yeah so okay
so what I did here is I put that Chester
heater into a sphere and I cut a hole in
the bottom of this chapter Hadrian and
the reason I do that is because if I
take your chest a hand round and a
spinet it makes a hole
oh and this is where we have the second
part of that video do you want the yeah
not quite yeah okay not yet with the
Bell okay let's see that hole I made
that hole in there uh-huh hey Jesse okay
so when you spin a test adjust ahed room
what are we what are we seeing when you
spin this well - when you spin it then
you're seeing that the earth is turning
okay and so there is a triangle in the
top of this form that turns into a
circle okay and that circle has a
relationship to the sphere of the earth
because these points touch all right so
what I did was is I find to find the
cone it would fit in that don't spill it
yet for the Bell we wait to the Bell
okay here we go okay if I drop a cone
into here I made the red part right
there you could see that it count that
it comes through the red point hits
there so this cone right here is what
goes from the top of that circle to the
point okay
so if I take this apart and I want to it
has scotch tape on it I want to take it
apart because there's something amazing
here going on again that is amazing I
don't know how to get this thing off or
that scotch tape works really good
anyway I keep teaching I'll get this off
to get this cone into a point I had to
make a little one okay yeah yeah great
thank you
okay now this is amazing this is what's
so amazing about this form look at this
I put this in here right
look at that alright so I made another
cone where these two these three touch
and these three touch can you see that
yes huh yes so you this cone Section
three actually touches six points right
and take this out same cone uh-huh
no this is amazing whoever thought that
was the same-sized cone uh-huh so what
it means is is that there's a cone that
goes around this as an earth is spinning
that is parallel to each other look
they're parallel uh-huh okay so that
means there can be energy that comes in
an energy that comes out okay so can you
go in and out yes yes yes okay look now
which is one of the reasons why we know
here we go here cause some more of this
stuff that drives a lots of people not
because I'm evacuating I'm sort of have
this bi-directional ah my directionality
that's right like an earth like a heart
asked have bidirectionality okay
now this is amazing here watching more
stuff coming here
put it back together is back together
you see this ring right here mm-hmm that
make from the call it's exactly the size
of that ring oh yeah yeah those rigs are
the same size which is what's it's a
balance below here are those rings oh
there's still Aurora yeah the Aurora
yeah yeah now it's interesting because
this is a Aurora at the North Pole
yeah a South Pole okay never in any of
the Rohrer pictures that you see is this
ever of is there ever a flash of any
kind of light that goes in the middle
yeah never the other end you have the
light that goes across uh-huh why
because this point is here oh and it's
flowing across into the other cone which
is about right here right and it's
coming out and you know this is the
other size of the larger cone underneath
and that's where the aurora borealis is
between the top cone and a bottom cone
mm-hmm that's why it gets cleaned up
like this and it gets swerved over more
as an oval interesting so that the the
chest ahed Rijn in the center has of
Earth the house even has to do with the
Aurora's yeah it does the way that the
earth breathes exactly
now here's the thing about this is that
the scientists don't know they don't
know this they cannot figure out that is
in any explanation for this opening at
the top being all black with a ring
around it and the bottom part with a
ring that doesn't Aurora doesn't go on
the outside of it but stays inside no
one can explain that no one I've looked
and looked and looked and
okay so
these are pretty subjective speculations
but it's based a little bit on a
lawfulness - as a little there's my form
is lawful so some of the things that I
can explain lawfully other people can
you can't you can't dispute that you
can't speak those cones sorry yeah
they're honest that's a moral
presentation mm-hmm this is not immoral
alright because they're reproducible
over and over again why is all about it
because this is the human heart geometry
this is all about the heart you guys if
I take the check - he drew and I tell
you that it's that sits in the body like
this you're gonna say no heart looks
like this the geometry doesn't look like
this but geometry is the way that you
design something it's not the end result
between the idea of a result of a
manifestation in our law on our world
there's a design there's a drawing all
right and if I take this and I blow a
bubble in this this is what it looks
like if you take it and blow a bubble in
it yeah all I have to do is dip this
into soap you could do it at home dip it
in a soap blow a bubble and this is what
the bubble looks this is called minimum
surfaces this is the way nature tries to
become sere when it's just geometry is
straight lines mm-hmm all geometric
forms in this one specially all of them
cubes whatever are all trying to become
a sphere it's called minimize surfaces
this is the shape of the left ventricle
the human heart and we have a abet beam
I have a video wrong picture here of the
human heart and this is a left ventricle
this is the right ventricle and we have
this - which is the digital asset oh my
gosh yes I've got this Ron can you pause
it quick - at the very end maybe you
couldn't wait a little bit before you
show that
okay then let's keep it going here then
yeah wait a little bit on that okay all
right all right so if I cut off the left
ventricle here of the right ventricle
and I remove it I'll hold this quick
this is what's left this is the human
heart and this is the form that he's
dead
Helen is holding so there is in any
geometry that I've seen and I've studied
his career chorionic studies that heart
researchers do on trying to explain what
the geometry is behind the human heart
and the closest they come up is with a
form they call a prolate but this the
prolate has a point on both ends this
does it is flat across just like this so
that's one thing that you can't say that
that the geometry is inorganic it is it
can be organic on a natural process but
just the left ventricle you said not
this is a left ventricle and what about
the right well the right is of just ahed
room that has collapsed on one side and
it hugs this one okay and I have
geometry studies showing that okay how
that works
okay one of the reasons one of the ways
I figured out this was the heart because
I I didn't find out it was a hartford
seven eight years high study study study
all right I saw a model of a heart and I
noticed that the butt at the apex this
is called an apex is called a base at
the apex it had kind of three ridges at
the bottom and then when a ridge came up
its flattened out then I knew I might be
on it well I might be on something so
next thing I did did was I tried to find
out that this the heart was at the heart
this is the jumper here the inside and
the outside of the heart if you put this
into a cube the sent root 3 as you know
mm-hmm and it sits in the body like this
oh it does yes
and so it's not it so it does sit at
this root 3 angle it doesn't sit look at
that
look how it sits sitting at a root 3
angle like that it sits at root 3
so this is a apex and this is the base
and that is an angle of root 3 and why
is it why would the whoever did this why
would they set it at root 3 and the
reason is because root 3 is the balance
I'll show you here root 3 is the balance
between forward and backwards right and
left and the top to bottom not root 2
root 2 is 2-dimensional the heart sits
in an angle like this had no heart
explanation 'el process has ever been
developed has shows that the hearts it's
that anything else that row 3 and why
because it was in a cube why because it
was a tetrahedron that was spun okay and
the tetrahedron is known as warmth okay
and the tetrahedron the Chester Haven is
between a cube and an octahedron the
cube is earth and the octahedron is air
the heart sits in the middle of the
chest have below the lungs
the octahedron is known as the kidneys
so the heart sits between the kidneys
and the lungs geometrically in the
Platonic forms I have even nothing to do
with inventing let me know when you're
ready for that video - now this is the
geometry of the inside of the heart so
the inside of the heart looks like looks
like that like this one here now
remember this is the inside of the heart
this is where this is the blood really
the heart has really got a cavity and
this is what's in the cavity and what
happens and that is this is in the
research I've got a website you can go
to called
heart istic science and in there I have
research done by Larry ologists
researchers that say well why is it that
the top doesn't move the midsection
moves and the apex doesn't hardly move
at all yeah yeah that's great
look that's these two circles going from
the top to the bottom that this is very
important everyone I'm gonna believable
could you see the six pointed star yeah
this isn't this isn't this is coming
from this work it's not coming from me
I'm not making this stuff up this is
what the okay
this form is a communicational device
and it in a way speaks to me it tells me
once I find something in it that there's
something else also and then there's
something else also Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom
Bom that's right Bom Bom
heartbeat heartbeat heartbeat bump bump
bump bump bump bump bump
the only thing that this doesn't show
this one is that this spins like that oh
yeah correct it's been okay great now we
can show the video as where we're
explaining the bump bump bump bump of
the heartbeat I want to have in this
asset that's coming up this was at
Frank's house when Brock took us over
there and and you can see the bump bump
bump up and Ron why don't you go ahead
and pause it like right around yeah sure
yeah so the the agreement is this one
that was just home yeah yeah Hornets on
here yeah okay yes this is the green one
and it's boat out and you can see the
jobs are behind it see it alright can
you stop it stop it alright so this is
the boat out one this is the shefte he
drew this one here is this one you can
see this triangle here yeah up at the
top then it's got this big spike like
this which is really two equilateral
triangles stretched out so as you turn
this this spins and this goes up and
down a little bit but not much
yeah how the outside goes up and down a
little bit not much it doesn't twist
like this yeah look doesn't twist yeah
not much no no no not much yeah barely
any disturb asically the form of the
chest ahed Rijn is just what enables it
to go just barely enough of a set
geometry
a sacred room the secret geometry they
can just barely enabling of our human
heart yeah yeah now show this is this
one the Allens joint and minimum
surfaces so that's the shape of the
blood okay and that's the shape of the
outside of the heart and that's the
inside of the heart okay let's see if we
can get it to turn outside of the heart
and the inside okay okay that's a hollow
space inside yeah awesome then Ron's
playing Jerry Braun's playing it again
for us yeah boom
and there's that rolls out a little bit
that's good twist look this one goes
blows out just a little bit
yeah and this one twists is that cool or
what yeah now this happens this
pulsation it happens nine tenths of a
second throughout your whole life
it happens in nine tenths of a second
every second every second you get about
two and a half billion heartbeats in a
lifetime now this is really cool 82 that
this design of this heart is based on
sacred geometry all of these drawings
are done with that stick okay wasn't
done with a big compass I had it would
don't with a stick then I refined it
with this with the big compass okay but
basically all this comes from sacred
geometry no measurements there are no
rulers there's just straight sticks now
the heart has a lot of people now are
saying the heart isn't a pump I don't
know if you've heard this but a lot of
people say that the heart doesn't pump
the blood okay
okay when what does it do okay telling
me it's not a pop okay what is it hmm
so from according to my research this
speaks to me like I told you this speaks
to me now when this this is pretty good
we could come back to it again do you
want to do the bell now I want to do the
bell now okay that's the second half of
that yeah great okay this is really cool
guys it shows the Chester Hebron there
it is and then it it comes out of the of
the big one once it reaches its point
works like this the blue part is like
this yo right there it will come out it
comes out yep and then it goes over here
top to you nice huh
yep and then I had him spin it yes and
when you spin it it turns into a bell it
turns into a bell okay
yes and of course then I made some a
design of a bell that's the design I
made on top of the Bell but this is the
Bell so the Chester Hayden when it spins
it turns into a bell no and what is the
purpose of the of that Bell this is what
happened I found this and this really
changed everything for me
I found this photograph of a temple in
Egypt and this is called the temple of
hathor how do I spell that Hathor pepper
ha ha ha ha
pepper pepper a tempo of ha / h AP or
hopper
I'm not sure I think yes hh-hey p le roi
OS hopper hahaha temple pepper temple i
have been talking so much and i have a
dry mouth and you're selling it right
there I start out Thor my H atah a th oh
ok I have time hard time pronouncing
some of my words after I talked for a
long time
interesting when we have the NDIS and
hearing it I did ok great
and the top of this is her temple is a
birthing temple where women go to give
birth have at 4000 years ago okay and
they go into this temple and on the
ceiling there is a princess and the
precipitous face her arms are coming
down here her body is here Benson her
legs there's her feet oh okay and she is
known okay Ron as yeah yeah the arms on
the on the right side and she's bending
over and the legs are on the left side
and it's a bent over with the arms down
there yeah okay so she there are
goddesses the goddess is called princess
newt newt and newt swallows the moon and
Naima's letter gives birth to the son oh
wow
and from the sun all these bells come
down to a cube
so the meal I knew that my form made
these belts oh the Bell is for the birth
the bell is the heart is the heart we
incarnate with our heart not with their
fingers not with our ears now with our
kidneys we incarnate into this world
into an embryo through the heart that's
what carries our karma that's what
carries our goals that carries our plans
the human heart which we're talking
about here with a chesty hatred so I
mean look at these where were these
where were these these are the bells of
Marche oh those are the bells this I
enlarge this piece oh I see what you did
so you could see that these are bells
yes these are human hearts incarnated oh
wow yeah okay now you can say on what
guy is really nuts cuz now look what
he's saying we like them the more nuts
to bet more nuts than ever now so the
thing is is that we incarnate with our
heart so that means that therefore okay
what we take in our heart in this life
is what we take out and what we bring
back in to do again Wow now so be very
vigilant with what that be very vigilant
and careful with what you take into your
heart in this life and what you do in
your life the moral part of your life
this is affecting because this is an
interval an intros between polarity and
priorities is everything that we
experience on this earth is all
polarities I mean I'm not kidding you
there isn't a thing so the life and the
death are the are the polarities and the
interval is the time in the bit in
between so heart is this heart yes
okay that's the organ and it balances
polarity or not about some polarities
not a part so here if you find my
compass again wherever it went there it
is an organ that balances polarities
this is a moral compass that has the
polarities everything on earth is
priorities and intervals and what and
intervals and in therefore between them
and this is where we live this is our
life from here to here
Wow this is in our life this isn't our
life this is birth as is death but in
this interval is what we do here on our
planet and what we have to do is to try
to find the interval in our life to be
able to balance these and what does that
as a human heart the human heart
balances polarities and is an interval
and it's an interval between octahedron
and the cube
it's an interval between the lungs and
the kidneys remember that the heart
takes a there are six to six lobes in
the human heart one of those lobes the
heart takes there's five left so this
interval right here if we get our heart
stuck on this side or on this side we
have what we known as heart attacks and
these heart attacks are either
congestive mm-hmm they're both
congestive but this one gets big that's
what shrinks mmm and that's depends on
what side you're on if you're going to
be stuck on a polarity you better find
some way to get out of it because
everything on this earth is set up to be
polarities that's why the earth is known
as what is different what's different
between this side and this side and
what's different between Zoo is the
heart in the middle of the cube yeah and
what is it doing it's spinning like this
yes it's going to this side and then it
goes to this side okay less than one
second your entire life 90 seconds boom
boom boom boom yes and now you can
actually explain some of these things
that people talk about in their
meditations and in whatever whatever
that they do and this is more subjective
even though some people may think it's
too subjective but remember that
the human heart is balancing between the
subjective and the objective its
balancing between math and art and in
between here is the culmination and
Einstein said that the highest form of
math is art and the highest form of art
is mathematical
yes he's saying here this is the
interval so what we have to do in this
life is to work with the interval and
help it balance everything that's
different good and bad male and female
all the opposites that are all
throughout our life from birth to death
the human heart is trying to balance
we go back to one
and only on earth can you do this and
only on earth can you develop a capacity
only on earth can you develop the heart
Aaron on the other side you can't help
develop the heart but you can plan for
how you can develop and then you can
incarnate and there's one philosopher
that says that the human heart before
incarnate our spinning bells at high
speeds going all over the place looking
for the right parents right environment
the right situation Wow
four-year for its development and the
heart the heart itself and that's
another reason why I like this so much
as if these Egyptians had clairvoyance
we don't mm-hmm we've lost the why oh we
lost it and you know we were lost it for
a good reason because we needed to
develop our senses we need to develop
our thinking our feeling our willing we
needed to develop our senses and we
couldn't do that during this time
because everything was coming through us
now things have to come from us hmm so
the human heart okay is what allows all
this to happen and you choose your
parents you choose the environment you
come into because you've got certain
things to do that certain environments
can help mm-hmm okay and that's what
we're looking you come with the mission
into playground earth we do now this is
what's really cool the heart enters the
embryo okay about two weeks two weeks
into about two weeks after inception
yeah and the heart okay is outside the
body it's like this the hearts outside
of the body when it's first outside the
embryo oh wow
and then it enters in Wow underneath the
chin like this and then enters in but
before that the hearts out here that's
coming in before the body okay already
has blood and veins in it that are
pulsating without the heart mmm
and then Wow the blood and you're in the
embryo is 100% independent of the
mother's blood that blood is the baby's
blood has nothing to do with a mother
that's your that's your blood that's
your heart and that's your blood and the
what goes through the heart is the blood
and that's what's driving the heart is
the blood the heart isn't driving the
blood the blood is driving the heart
when all of this is coming from what
this geometry tells me it talks to me in
a way that I can understand
geometrically what possibilities are I
mean they don't even know the geometry
of the Bell I took this to a Bell expert
he bought he bought fell off his chair
when I spun it he says we don't we were
Russians and we know that the best weed
but we make the best belt I said well
how did you do it then you didn't have
this
he says trial and error this is not
trial and error
yeah so this is what I do know and I
have some other things about the human
heart that's really neat I figured out
how the blood runs through the heart
okay what's amazing is the blood comes
into the heart clockwise and leaves
counterclockwise hmm opposite you see
that I mean by polarities mmm clockwise
counterclockwise coming out of our heart
how this chat to Hebron look I figured
out how to do that mm-hmm
there's no gears in here there's no
poise there's not a bunch of Springs
there's there there's a pulleys or so
years or so come so coming in I'm saying
clockwise coming in going out yes in
here and this is twice the size as this
and yet the speed that goes through the
heart coming in and going out same speed
yep this is half the size of this so our
heart captures our karmic what happens
in the in life and stores it for the
next snack it carries the the life it
carries the life because it's between
birth and death and between those is
life well an interval is life an
interval is life between birth and death
and what is accumulated through
experience to the heart carries on
through spirit into next absolutely it
doesn't go out for your liver
what is the brains role in
of the interval right well the brain is
an interval okay the heart is brain is
because an organ is an organ yeah I mean
even though the heart is an organ - but
the heart has the heart is more the
feeling life or the brain is more
conception perception it's more than
thinking Rome okay
and the hearts on the feeling or the
heart is in the soul room the solar soul
have the soul and this is their thinking
I was so in this out here the will
assist
this is what I do my will is driving I
have a very strong will in that in the
chest ahed Hren being inside of being
inside of Earth this is the Earth's
heartbeat that's right now you go on
internet put in aurora borealis and
there's some aurora borealis images from
outer space that nASA has taken that
shows the aurora and the the earth is
quite small and the aurora at the top is
moving like this this is so perfect
Aurora's moving counterclockwise
clockwise counter clockwise clockwise
counter clock at it right there
Aurora moves like this as does it has
also it has a pulse we just interviewed
in NASA was that we we just interviewed
a NASA astronaut that spent 50 days in
space and we should have asked if we
would have known now we tell it right
now we know to ask about this way though
all you gotta do is go on internet shows
it a video of oh yeah
shows it doing this and that's the
heartbeat of the earth it is you see
another thing that the forum has taught
me that the scientists well I don't know
if they agree or disagree I don't know
but the Aurora okay that you see okay
it's coming out of the heart coming out
of the other earth and not coming in it
comes in through the black hole but it
leaves so the roar that you see okay is
leaving
that's not entering the Aurora is always
leaving always oh it comes in comes in
huh then it hits the bottom of the point
it goes across and back up so when you
see this Aurora here that's coming out
of the earth yeah this one yes this one
is still in the center reaching to go up
out well this isn't coming in this is
going out did you have any idea the
chest ahed Rijn was related to the heart
and to the earth and did you have any
inkling and the in the javanese bytes of
that it was showing you that or was it
all all of this come from me yeah yeah I
don't have a man thar that's teaching me
yes yes the the mentor I have is a
tetrahedron yeah yeah that's my method
are you were finding the 7 by 507 I had
no clue what it was it took me I think I
took me seven to eight years before I
even had an inkling there was a heart
and then I've been working 12 years on
on is it the heart yeah seven eight
years Stephen find the chest ahed Hren
and then to about 12 years to figure out
that it has to deal with the heart and
the earth well this get evidence to get
evidence to get evidence the Chester
Haven you know I have a lot of people I
have some people that say it's not
accurate
I'll have mathematics in my book it
shows this exactly accurate I mean but
all these things that come at you and so
I'm sticking my neck out right well I
don't care if the hell I don't care if I
stick out my neck disprove me come on
tell me where I'm wrong I want give me
some advice yeah I get zero yeah and I'm
not a nut you know I mean I have
children you know this is geometry this
isn't some fantasy thing I'm going
through here yeah yeah and you walked us
through the twig on the beach and how
you can make the seed of life and the
flowers I showed you how to make just a
mother twig okay a twig with the branch
that's why I sorry I I wasn't as
accurate as if I use the regular compass
but I wanted to emphasize that this is
sacred and that's that twig will make
perfect circles if it was in the sand
not on this piece of paper with an
eraser but it did make it it did show it
even though I the twig wasn't very
accurate last my phone not the twig
Frank I want to know what you would do
what do you what do you think about do
you think that the sacred geometries and
chesta hedron's do you think this is our
ticket to having that global unity that
we need to work together the secret to
that global unity is the heart but it's
based on the on that person soul versus
it's a soul organ it's based on that but
if the more that you understand the
heart in the geometry and actually try
to practice it with a stick or a real
compass the more it'll make you
healthier in your view yeah you'll
become more healthy in your thinking not
now you're gonna come smarter and gonna
get da more one another said you'll
become more healthy so that you can
handle the polarities because they're
everywhere
do not get stuck with one of them know
that the heart will help you balance it
it's all about you you know
the blood is you and it runs through the
heart and that's that's gonna help
this will help humanity in the end
somehow yes yes I'm not going to be here
when it does but somehow this geometry
came in
I almost died of a heart problem I had
two brothers that died of heart problems
so my name is Chester which is a chest
and I called the Cheka Haven because it
since this is a a hadrian a polyhedron
in the chest yes yes so I came in one of
the things that you look at is to figure
out why you came here what was the
purpose well one of the things that you
can do to find out closer to what you
came here to do is to look at your
parents and find out what they were good
at not what they became when you have
that kind of stuff they were good at
what they were good at and that's the
reason you chose them and that has
something to do about your choice why
you came here
this there's still so much to talk about
regarding that oh my on this is what I
do is in my life this is my interval I'm
living my interval what's what else is
good is that you even though like you
just said that the chest ahed Rijn may
may it may take time past your lifetime
you've done what you've needed to do
with passing this information on to
young people will continue awakening and
inspiring to this this information the
heart to the unity to even something as
simple as to the twig with the branch to
be able to make the flower of life and
the seed of life see yes and and and
it's just a he drew from that
yeah the but the main thing is to
understand here is that all of this that
I have done is not traditional this is
the future the future isn't looking at
the flower of life or whatever if that's
why that exists is to teach you what
happened in the past so you can take
that and go into the future this is the
future and I've given you ways that I
found this that can be applied that I
haven't seen anybody apply nobody's
taking the chest nobody's taking the
platonic forms and spinning them none of
nobody's opening them up and I've been
doing this for 20 years and I've put
everything have a hundred and ninety-two
videos on YouTube to give away my work
to try to get people to stop making
Flower of Life and taking crayons or
felt pens and coloring I'm indifferent
that's just not it that's not work
that's of the past has been left for you
for a good reason he the spiritual world
left all the nature here to trees
animals whatever and they took off is it
okay now we'll see what you can do huh
how about giving back to us a little bit
that's what I tried to do I'm trying to
give back because I can take this across
the threshold
they don't have this on the other side
it could only be developed on earth and
that's why it's so important your life
is so important because you need to take
something back and give back for your
life and that has to be done on earth
not on some other planet or some other
solar system or other galaxy has to be
done here on earth where everything is
different this is where you can be
different and you can be different in a
productive way and you can choose
anything you don't have to just choose
geometry you could choose anything that
you can develop yourself and the only
thing you could cross the crash hole
with and go to the other side whenever
that happens is your capacity and
capacity can only bow out here cross
this across this wrestling you cannot
develop your capacity Frank this has
been such a fascinating time together
I'm really grateful oh yeah I'm so happy
that I can share it thank you
you've allowed me to share it thank you
very much thank you my god very well
thank you thank you for sharing thank
you thank you for sharing everything
that you've shared this throughout this
conversation thank you Ron for producing
and directing we're very grateful for
you thank you and I show Ron one thing
he asked me about the Pentagon
Ron are you ok with that
sure yeah here's the Pentagon yes now if
I take this one arm of the Pentagon here
and I slip it under this one I take this
one here and go like this it looks like
this mm-hmm
it's becoming three-dimensional now if I
take and slip another one under another
arm mr. Chester Hadrian the Chester he
turn is based on the five pointed star
the pentagram
these are arms off the pentagram three
of the arms three of these arms you take
any pentagram you want to draw draw it
accurate and take three of these off
fold them together you get shefte he
drew and when you take it together and
you're good and you've set it down it
makes a triangle at the bottom and the
same size on the sides there I found
other ways to find this this form is
outstanding it's unbelievable how much
it is and there's still things I haven't
shown you that how I also discovered it
we'll have to have you back there's a
there's a lot to consume uh ch2
continued online about sacred geometry
given us so many important pointers and
tips that hopefully for other people has
resonated is for other people yes yes
correct that's what we do every episode
every episode is for others to get
engaged and inspired with yes it's the
future Frank thank you again so much for
coming on the show thank you for putting
up with all my talk we loved it we loved
it I want to give it again a huge thank
you to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing huge thank you to the viewers
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know also check out the link below to
Frank Chester calm and go and have more
conversations with your friends your
family or coworkers online on social
media get talking about the chest ahijon
about sacred geometry get practicing it
together let's get there together
everyone support the organizations the
entrepreneurs the artists around the
world
believe in support simulation our links
are below let's get inspired to that
unity and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon
[Music]
[Music]